all right hello everyone its he karna
who are here I'm gonna be doing the
broadcast tonight on the HS comp which
channel so if there anyone wants to send
me messages I'll be following the
twitch.tv slash chests channel for the
time being so if anyone has questions I
ask it there and I will try to respond
as best I can so all right so I think
I'm noticing there's Dulles he's here
again he was he was here last night too
and so I start off by playing last night
so I think I'll start by playing him
again tonight and see how it goes
so d4 I'll play b6 play this good ol
Owens defense see how it goes this time
so II 6 maybe d5 next or 97 and we'll
see okay so Knight f3 I'll play 97 Queen
- I'll play g6 probably hopefully h4
he'll play C foreign and Queen e2 like
this he did this a couple of times
against me last night - he didn't have a
lot of success bit odd but he was also
very slow so maybe now the time zones
more convenient to for him it should be
100 castle
probably he'll play 8 3 I assume the 96
and I see that that Burke writes this
doesn't look like man versus machine
that's a good comment actually because
normally when you see such setups I mean
I'm pretty well known for playing the
set up against computers so it would
seem that yeah
Burke has a point this is not a man
versus machine so he's probably confused
as to why I'm playing this opening
nevertheless I think the position is
pretty reasonable so clean aight b3
probably he'll go rookie two and then i
might play a four or I might just take
on e6 I'm not sure probably I'll play
out for though points with an item b3
that this rook on a1 is not ideal
I see HTF each to fp0 rights while
Dulles is a man
well Dulles is a man so if you well if
you assume dose is a man that's
basically man vs. machine so that is
correct
so played a four hero probably played
Bishop to see one I'm guessing maybe
Bishop c2 is possible probably just
Bishop c1 and now I could take I could
also do something interesting like
knight c6 but I think I'll just play it
simple I'll just take the pawn I'm I'm
definitely going to take his Bishop and
a mover to now here he plays rook do you
want so if I want to I can take to take
the bishop I can move my queen I think
I'll just take the bishops he'll take
back obviously now I'll play I think
I'll play c5 here and beets the problem
here for white is this rook on any a2 is
not well placed and so he plays the e5
trying to free the bishop on its
diagonal but I suspect that here I can
just take you take I'm just gonna play
Knight f5 he wants to take I'll just
play workout 5 this this point II five
is pretty loose here so there are some
issues for Roy so he does take so I'm
gonna take back I'll probably work d1 I
assume hopefully clean off eight this
position is probably equal because even
though I'm about to win a pawn he does
to this very nice outpost on e4 for his
Knight so Bishop e5 rook d7 I can play
work f7 I can also have played rook da I
kind of like work f7 Morris it takes
I'll take place between b7 so worked you
wanted to now I'll take on c3 he takes
it the Queen I'll click Queen d6 if he
takes with the pawn and I'll probably
just I'll probably just play like rook
d8 and just play the position but now
after Queen d6 I think I'm just I'm
looking pretty good here I'm off upon
this pawn I wish this poems on have 5 RF
6 of course but still it is a pawn and I
am controlling this D file which is also
very important I'm gonna put it work on
d8 not smooth and I'll see what happens
so he plays age 4 play rook e8 keep
control of this this is this D file here
Queen f3 play e5 support the pawn on f4
and and also I can always click hang out
6 if I need to UM
to further reinforce so h5o plea public
we need six here try to attack this pawn
also also free up something along this
uh this defiled here use my rook as the
queen queen is nicely placed there but I
can't really do much with it so a few
seven so he takes all take and now let's
see what what we do all right so I'm
sorry about that I just realized my
batteries Rose so he plays Queen b8 um
so now I can take on c4 I'll probably
take on any five that's not great if I
play rook e7 which I think I will do so
now he's probably no clean h8 but I
think here I can maybe take or just play
coin off sex and just try to play the
position anyway um so queen h7 I'll go
King f8 Queen age six King H King g8 is
my plan cuz Queen h3 naga king g7 2 is
nono square is here here's nothing long
as the eighth-ranked really and now I'm
threatening to maybe play just push this
pond like forward to e 43 so Queen D 3
click Queen up 5 between these 6 I'll
play Queen e6 and now when he goes Queen
dieter I'm going to go Eve for now I'm
gonna start to use these pawns as extra
pawn that I have here on the center to
try and just push it down the board and
he goes Queen d2 he'll hang c4 as well
so please Queen b8 so I can take on c4
if I want to which I really do actually
but I don't really the positions not
conducive for it so I kind of want to
see if I can do something else but I'm
not seeing it so I'm just gonna play e4
here and he'll probably take on a 4 I'll
take on c4 maybe work do you wanna play
Queen e6 of roof d6 25 or clean out 5
probably so I'll play I'll play click
Queen of 5 here but I just a lot of
Queen h4 or queen be a it so now I'm
gonna go III Shack I'll go clean your
sex it was Queen inch to I think I can
just go kimchi 5 maybe
Queens you 3 king off sick
for a cafe workout seven cooking a seven
all the here he's Richie seven he's
running out of time though did he just
fly he just did he lack or did he just
flag there one of the two happened I
don't know which one um that was weird
that was very weird I don't know what
happened there so I'll rematch him see
if he wants to play another game
um again as with previous previous times
I've done this including last night
people want to donate $5 or more I'm
more than willing to play a blitz or a
bullet game with them so if you are
interested and I'll be paying attention
to that as well so okay so d3 and now he
aborts the game that was weird so that's
okay that was weird so he BOTS the game
I guess he left her something I don't
know if he was lagging and what that
what that was all about cuz he usually
he had like 15 seconds winning flag my
last game so I don't know what that was
but anyway let's see so I think maybe
I'll look to see if there are any people
in bullet I challenged a Mon cam VP
challenging the other guy oh sorry and
as a as chess pages just pointed out um
and she I believe I believe that's a
woman I believe she she wrote he car no
one can donate because we're streaming
on trust which not not twitch uh-huh
yeah that's right sorry I started
laughing because I saw this other
message from chat sucks for your rights
can I donate blood I'm afraid this is a
this is a chest chest chest channel this
isn't like a vampire channel or
something I don't think those donations
are welcome so okay maybe we'll try and
play this guy J a surprise up that
bullet um
he's 27 17 it says Norway is that like
Johann Sebastian someone I think it is
but I'm not sure and when I see Dulles
has returned again so I'll challenge him
of blitz
okay and so yeah so I'm playing golf
again the match continues what's going
on he just supported for a second time
as he uh he trying to troll me or
something that was very weird
okay so again if anyone has any
questions of course I'll I'll try to
respond to them as best I can
so yeah so so far it seems fairly quiet
in the chat
all right so okay so jazz president want
to play let's see who else is uh I might
just play people randomly now for a
little bit if if no one wants to play I
mean I challenged him on he seems to not
want to play at the moment a Baku
another guy may be extreme hunger okay
so I could go okay here we go so now I'm
playing Dulles I guess he wanted to
abort so you could get white again I
don't really understand the point of
that but alright for I'll play d5 try to
force him to clarify the structure so he
doesn't get some F he wants to play off
five obviously I'm so I'll play c5 c3
Knight e7 and I have three I'll play
Queen d7 maybe to play bish basics maybe
and the Queen covers it's a four square
also so you know so we'll see what he
wants to do here maybe you'll play Queen
e2 maybe he'll play just castles
chef's may ask who are you playing first
in the World Cup to be honest I don't
actually know I haven't looked at the
first I know several the later pairings
that I possibly have but I haven't
looked at the first round offhand I know
it's someone around like I think 2250
2,300 on so I'll take a look once once I
start preparing seriously and a couple
of days once I get to Athens Greece
um the moment I'm just trying to relax
and enjoy myself I know that in the
second round I think I'm probably
playing assuming I went I'm probably
playing bruising or I believe Anton
we are the guy that I beat in Gibraltar
the last two years so I know that much
so Knight takes b5 I can play a six here
if I want to I think I will just get the
get rid of this night because these
squares could be weak so Bishop e7
probably he'll play a three here maybe
not I'm not really sure so he plays work
c1 I'm just gonna retreat my night
before you can play a three
so he plays 91 now I know I kind of have
to figure out what I'm trying to play
for so I can play f5 if I want I can
play h5 two on neither of those moves
looks horribly attractive to be honest
cuz I mean I kind of figure out where my
King is going here so I'm gonna play
something a little bit weird I'm gonna
play Bishop f8 and put the bought
cheese sob and basically admit that I
made a mistake putting ie7 and put it on
the other diagonal now I'll put age 5 to
stop g4 and saw it stopped Knight g4
also so then I d7 he can take care if he
wants to but I'll just take with my king
and then I should be doing okay
doesn't look too bad not yet at least
although this could get bad in a hurry
but if I'm not careful and he got some
kind of h3 chief for this could get
really ugly so I can cast here I don't
necessarily want to I can also take
maybe that looks very iffy but but let's
see but why not let's let's see what's
gonna happen here so it helps Hank I'll
play knight c6 a gun he can play Knight
e5 v a couple different ideas here but
so far at least my king is not too loose
it's not it's not great here but it's
not no it's not to lose it's not yet at
least
so I can run my King over to like b7 or
something I probably can survive this I
please 97 Sonoma go they go broke a 7
maybe it's an 85 I didn't actually seen
a d7 saule pleureur k7
this is kind of gotten pretty ugly so so
we'll see so so King in the center it's
movie night g5 oh yeah I miss us pay
said yes actually yeah I didn't know
that actually it's um it's I think it's
a Pakistan Jeon yeah he's from Pakistan
or Bangladesh or one of those two
countries
I think I'm not I'm not certain I feel
like that's correct but I'm not certain
so I've got myself into just an
absolutely terrible position here so I'm
just hoping that I can maybe flag him or
he makes a slight error and then I'm
okay exists still white is much better
but it's not it's not gone yet so here I
can maybe take maybe I can take and play
97 or something um let's see can I take
I don't see why I can't take I mean I'm
completely busted almost no matter what
I do here so please 96 but can't I take
you and take on these seven with on 18
Queen g7 work up seven Queen g5 King d6
Queen g35 he takes it upon and go King
e6
Oh what is whoa
Queen g6 and I just take his Queen what
was that what was that
that was really unfortunate okay so
that's two games so far to me so
definitely I didn't deserve to win that
second one but on but he just too got
careless there my lady for probably
takes 94 plays d5 so now I'll castle b4
c4 5 oh no play Bishop 8 3 here just to
take away this night before square maybe
do something along this long diagonal
possibly so Rickie Adel play Knight c3
now there's a lot of pressure on this
pawn on e6 I'll play Knight f4 take
probably just gonna exchange everything
here on D on d5 and I'm gonna go like
rook c1 and no maybe it works e5 is an
idea
please rook c8 and play will see five
five one two but I wanna see if there's
something better I can do like maybe f3
at some point I'll play Queen c2 here
and as Taylor 969 says Greece for hauled
is no actually I think I mentioned this
on my my stream last night
Athens won a few place which has some
direct flights to Tbilisi Georgia and so
I figured I'll do sort of a training
camp in Georgia around in Greece and not
all go to on and I'll go from the
original easy
okay so clean 75 and now black is
products this pawn is very very strong
now in t5 and I suspect it's correct
play black still is completely fine but
it's getting a little bit unpleasant now
so he plays rook d8 I can play Bishop c4
I can maybe play Queen C forks he's not
turning to actually take the take my
pawn here on on d5 so Queen c4 looks
interesting
do I have any other moves that make
sounds Bishop c4 just King h8 probably
but I don't see any other moves that
make a whole lot of sense maybe I'll try
something interesting I'll try b4 to try
and play b5 and really take take
advantage of this this this the way he's
put his I sorted his pieces here on the
C file um it's a rook d6 I think I'll
play if I play b5 ego c5 obviously by
tink he takes and I don't have a whole
lot I think I'm gonna play Queen c5 here
and probably hopefully b6 but maybe not
I'm not sure so he does look like Queens
before I'll give him c5 he wants and
then I'm gonna go clean a sex is well
that's my plan now I'll play a three and
if I can get a Bishop to c6 that's
that's that's really the dream if I
somehow can get get a bishop to square
that I'm doing fantastically well so I
might get I might get that actually
so--but which would be five King h7 I'll
put a bishop on c6 now probably he'll
take on b4 doesn't have to but his
attack over here on the Kings side is
very very slow at the same time so I
think now I'm gonna bring my queen back
to f1 maybe go for h3 because this
because I'll have something his diploma
bleep end on each four so please push b5
don't be 5 to make sure that I fix this
pawn structure here on on the King saw
on the Queen side sorry
it's a Bishop f6 now I'm gonna click G
for how much I'm really gonna try and
play it planet issue this rooks here are
pretty clumsy on d6 and d7
and also with this pawn structure where
the P is the two versus one but the pawn
on b5 fixes them this this should be
fine for me to try and play a play over
here on the on the King side and also
his pawns are a little bit weaker here
on the light squares potentially I might
be able to attack them with my bishop
later on so please the h3 I think I'll
take probably Bishop e5 I'll play King
g2 it goes burke h6 i might go king up
one i might just play work h1 if you
plays rook g6
I can play king h1 if I want to I don't
know if I want to king each one he's
probably gonna keying off six rookie g1
it's a pawn but I don't really see the
point I'm gonna try to play play here on
got my King to the center and then try
and play against these weak pawns here
on the center on out 584 so Bishop d6
I'm gonna play work h1 now because now
it's working on c7 still a little bit
clumsy here and again my bishop is much
better than his bishop and these pawns
here are a little bit weak or too so
Richie - I'll play with h5 if King g6
I'll play work h1 I really want to get
to works on the H file if I can so a 4 I
take he takes my clear work H 1 try to
get something on h7 but he doesn't III
which I forgot about but now I can go d6
maybe work up to King D 3 takes Chuck
Chuck Chuck um what is going on here
I can can I check it I think I'm gonna
play d6 workout takes King d3
and now I get the shock and let's how
can you define here
he doesn't kini five names so I'm gonna
have to flag him unfortunately as much
as I don't want to
so how can he
okay so yeah that wasn't perfect but
okay so so it's an ox game okay sis so
I'm off to a good start tonight Torino
against dauntless a little bit lucky the
second game this that last I'm probably
sure gonna draw up but time is a part of
the game and and you got you got to use
it to your advantage when you when you
have more time so push we aged four
plays six I'll draw back the age for
here is that he's trying to do something
here on the kingside but it's a little
bit hard now to Castle kingside so what
White's King is a little bit a little
bit it's a little bit unclear where this
King is going so b4 I'll play a five a
three I know I'm gonna play out five
here
and now with him having throwing age 46
is pong Carver's the g5 square like why
would like to get a knight to e6 but but
it's very hard and so g3 I'm gonna
castle and now the problem for white
they're also the white has to figure out
um what he's doing here like is he gonna
Castle kingside he's gonna Castle
queenside with what exactly is doing so
please h5 now I can play f4 if I want to
I can also just take on V form and do
something but I don't want to go g5 here
and he can take on f5 if he wants to I
think but I might have efore and then B
takes 8a takes b4 also they're actually
no if he takes him I can take on b4 and
play e4 and I'm gonna win some material
I'd like to show it on the board but I
shot on the board I might end up making
an accidental pre move and and that
would be unfortunate so he takes on e5
so now he's really like it takes on 85
what is he gonna take on a5 or not I'm
just gonna take and give him the offer
for me again to take on at 5 so I really
ain't taking on a5 now it's gonna be bad
because it's probably gonna let me play
like something like c6 and really just
break up this the Sun or the white house
although I guess here he could sack on
g5 too but he chooses not to so I'm
gonna take probably go play Knight e4
before I don't know which one I'm
one of the two at any rate took place 94
that's kind of what I expect nothing so
I want to I can play c6 here or you can
see 5 maybe 6 so looks very c6 looks
very attractive ah it's too hard to
resist playing seasick so I'm just gonna
do it
so tags tags okay so let's see oh sorry
it took on g5 but now can't I take on
East Romanian just take I take on eatery
takes I take on g5h and squished about
six minutes five but it's hard to
believe this can be good for white so
let's see so he takes I'm chief I'm not
let just take also takes Bishop g5 and
then play something like Queen he ate
maybe looks very dangerous so if I take
take h6
that's the starting point so it should
spin about six Queen H 597 you know we
need some Queen g6 Canyon shaped okay so
nineteen g5 solicits if I take on d5
here he plays 96 I think he takes
probably that's not good but it's not
clear so what to do here so I can play
93 maybe 93 upbeat spree and Bishop c8
if I'm really worried about the sack and
I think I am I I don't I don't I don't
believe the sack is okay for white but
I'm just gonna be I'm gonna be pragmatic
here and just put the bishop here
prevent this because even without the
Jeep on White's still very
underdeveloped I mean you have all these
pieces here in the center which aren't
doing a whole lot so I'm gonna take he's
gonna take
I'll go d5 if he takes I'll take I
want to open up this long diagonal here
if I can on this h88 one diagonal some
point if I can get a foreign you know
something like this for example
so probably he'll actually if he takes I
can take with the rook Navy know that me
please do something so I'll just tape
with the pot you can play Queen b3 here
probably then I'll just move my king out
of the way
so please queen g4 what does Queen do
for us now I'm gonna take off I take he
goes Queen takes 84 so that's what point
you for us okay so if I take he takes I
played rook rook out six and let's see
so does he have something here or not
it's between your seven king of eight
seven I can just take you should proceed
for I guess is his idea and if I play
rook I play king e8 probably go play
like rook d1 I'll play Knight d7 just to
make sure that I cut this diagonal or
not diagonal sorry the file here not to
DN White's King is also weak to here so
now I mean now I'm gonna take on a three
because this King here is also very
stuck in the center for white so please
Queen g8 I'll just play Bishop about
fate
please Queenie for I think I'll just
click Queen before Seraph d2 I actually
forgot about that move that was a bad
choice of like teeny 795
in d5 up the work they just to cut Queen
da track off 25 I'll play 96 I didn't
expect Bishop there so that was bad he
had rook d7 and Queen v8 made as well
but that somebody's not anything he was
gonna take on e6 when he went when he
took on e6 if I go back right here I
could have played rook F to Chuck or
yeah I could have played work up to
Chuck not what if that was just one that
won the game on the spot but I didn't
think you would take I thought he's
gonna play work piece of and Chuck right
away so that worked out better than it
should have
so okay so night six I'll put a
three-cheese six night of three we're
gonna play something pretty similar I
think what we just had d4
I'll take I take Knight f6 Bishop e2
probably play c4 we have this a couple
times last night as well this exact same
position so soon he wants to do it so
Queen d6 I'll play Knight c3
and so rook b8 all those click Queen d2
here play for put my works on d1 and c1
probably looks like the ideal spot
perfect harmony for the rooks although
here you could take on c4 so that kind
of was a bad idea
but because now black doesn't I've
doubled doubled pawns on a C file but at
the same time I mean it's not this is
not the end of the world this positions
still completely fine for white it's
just I I let him off the hook or is it
or as the football reference goes what
does that football reference we we knew
we are who we thought they were
something like that at any rate
submission b6 I'll play with d1 but now
his pawns here aren't aren't perfectly
placed in facts and often Itay for
offering exchange of the bishops and now
I'm going to try to play against these
pawns that are there a little bit
misplaced here on c6 and d5 so we're c8
all play Bishop d3 offer an exchange of
the bishops
and so let's see what he wants to do it
here and yeah again you guys if you have
if you have questions so you know let me
know so we're just have something about
a Rolex again I think so play okay so I
can play Knight a4 and play rook c3 oh
no Playworks c3 here a c5 and now I
think I'm gonna play Knight d3 if you go
c4 I can take the pawn and because now
with my eye on d3 I cover the C 1 square
so if I want to take a pawn I can take a
pawn here I can play 95 but I think I'll
just take and actually if you take to
the pawn the night may be good quante
595 good those works before so I'll just
take I'm taking now of course the knight
on d3 I'm covering the C 1 square I can
block with the rooks or up da twirps c3
now you can play Knight c5 here I don't
know if it's the best move it's probably
drawing as my guess but it's let's see
so what can I do this all play g4
ok 3 work C to g5 I'll play h3 to
protect the pawn on g4 and I try to
bring my king over if I can it's gonna
be pretty hard to win this I think this
is probably just a draw with correct
play but you never know so he goes f6
but now I can go rook b7 and pick off a
pawn if we get a 4 vs - I'm actually
gonna make this a three versus one on
the Ummat on the kingside play we're
gave six force the King back and then
I'm gonna go like rookie h5 so goes King
e5 so i'm liver kick Ricca 8 h5 Keeney
for I'm gonna go work at 5 and now is
just completely winning
naca if you're in distress type in the
chat I don't think I'm in distress I'm
doing pretty well so far so so not a big
deal
Lewis white bass says knock it as a
football kind of guy I don't know about
him a football kind of guy but generally
I do follow football I mean it is one of
the sports I do follow quite a bit huh I
talk he's probably my was a sport that I
followed the most but football
definitely is is the second sport that I
follow after um after ice hockey she's
six repeat six knowledge take the pawn
he takes King f1 and it's just a known
known endgame which is just winning
since I've broken two pawns connected
against a rock pretty much all the time
when you get to to connect working to
connected against against the Rockets
it's almost always winning there are a
few exceptions but they're very rare so
let's see it so Queen e2 awfully d5
again he takes I'll take Knight f3 I'll
play Queen h5
this fee for all the steak I'll offer an
exchange of Queens now and if you if he
wants exchange Queens you can if not I
mean it's just gonna be a normal
position so I'll play Knight f6
counseling to play Queen e4 try to force
his clean away from E to without much
luck
I played Bishop d6 993 Queen off five
probably simplicity for all this castle
like Queen now five I'm gonna put the
night on d7 probably we'll see what he
wants to do here please rip d1 with a
ninety seven positions looking pretty
pretty reasonable for me again rook e1 I
could play Bishop b4 here but I really
kind of I'm starting to like this Bishop
on d6 so I'm gonna just play like it's
gonna play a6 prevent night b-52h 3 play
okay so he wants to do something over
here now you might might want to play g4
or do something some weird stuff so I'm
just gonna play h6 practical new prevent
anything a3 I'll play clear cafee a I'm
gonna go a 5 here I think I think e 5 is
mine up smooth although he plays b4 so
I'll play Bishop f8 I'll just drop the
bishop back c5 now is no temple and that
would free up to d5 square for my knight
so now please g4 I'll play Queen Age 795
will play a 5 once exchange you can
exchange he doesn't Knight d5 here but I
think I might be 500 let's play rook ECE
or even just Chuck the exchange with a
b4
so so adore me says what languages do
you speak except English greetings from
greetings from North the only length I
speak with some proficiency at the Mount
besides English's is Italian I speak a
little bit of Spanish and Japanese but
it's very spattering and snow or near
nowhere near a proficient at any rate so
makes b7 LT dc5 now I've given them
these pawns here but tinnitus again to
whom this this two versus one on the
queenside which is not very smart of me
but for now it looks ok especially if I
can get this Knight to d5 possibly or
even play like work a3 next move and the
problem here is my queen is bad that's
that's and that's the biggest problem I
have in this position is that I have a
bad queen on h7 but it can also get into
the game very quickly along this
diagonal
- so Queen B - play working-age if you
take some outfit all this play King f8
b5 and now I've got to figure out what
I'm doing so if I take he's probably
going to c6 and that could be really
disastrous so I'm gonna play queen g6
and now I'm definitely gonna try and
take advantage of the fact that white
played a white plate h3 and G Forks I'm
definitely gonna look look to sac on
deep on g4 now
so that the Brooke twirler says hey
knock is your wall oranges at a
projector screen that is actually the
color of the wall behind me I had a
couple people earlier today Ashe tell me
that's a terrible color um so I I don't
know why they said that but I think all
that people judge for themselves as they
think it's good or not so be 690 xg4 so
now I'm threatening 93 with Chuck mate
with the discovery on the King if he
takes on g4 I think this is probably
just a draw but maybe I can play like
rookie a4 or something here I mean this
is working for work I mean I don't know
if root K 4 works it looks interesting
so Rho K for b7 Queenie for King you to
work - for king of one Queen inch
through Keaney - and I don't have
anything it doesn't look like is there
any way I can somehow I don't really see
anything here but I'm just gonna see if
I can do something so I'll click Queen
chief actually why did I play Queen g5
not given enough one that was stupid of
me very stupid of me in fact now I gave
him King off one I know it's not in
trouble
although he doesn't have a whole lot of
time again he's being incredibly slow
it's this one thing I noticed is that
he's been very very slow throughout so
Rick b3 so now if I get b7 I'm just I'm
doing fantastic it's a queen e5 so I'll
just take now have 96 I have the check
on check on a as a check on g4 so Queen
B - probably is 95 or B 597 King g8 so
he plays a 96
what does 96 - don't play rook e1 he
takes all checked and now I'm gonna take
and now he's gonna play like Queen g3
now now again he has no time there's no
time and he's getting needed probably
attack he's just made it in one so
that was not perfect play from Dulles
but anyway moving on let's see if he
wants playing war if he's he's done for
now um he left the room so that means
he's probably done so I'm gonna see if I
can play Yakov I guess or not Oracle a
doll is a gun if he's he's ready for
more error I guess he's not okay so I'm
gonna see if I can't play Yakov that um
Yakov has changed his formula it seems
like I can't seem to challenge him some
way it's like a lot of people I'm
noticing it's saying your challenge is
not matched remembers current settings I
don't know why that is that seems to be
happening a lot more a lot more than
usual of late at least so so Rab Krish
asks does the name does my name have
anything to do with with any trace this
back to Japanese I think Japanese
ancestors um yes I am actually
half Japanese so I do have relatives who
do live in Japan so so yes I am half
Japanese in the name as it is Japanese
last name so let's see so who's who's
here I'm gonna reload the webpage
quickly let's see
so let's let's see so okay so no I'm
back let's see the shock of want to play
it doesn't look like he wants to play at
the moment
let's check the bullet let's see who's
on ok the same guys can VP is on but I
guess I don't know if he's not playing
or what he's doing maybe I can play the
Lancer or again a lot of my challenges
is I keep getting this does not match
the the user settings or something along
those lines I don't know what that what
that's all about
[Music]
so who else is on normy TV is on
maybe he'll play ok so let's see so I'm
gonna play some bughouse well I'll make
it interesting now let's see will this
show up someone just asked me to play
bughouse me I'll play a game or not
maybe not oh I'll just get back to
playing regular chess ok so dollars
challenges me again so I don't know
what's going on he seems to always abort
when he's black to get white the next
game is like the third time he's done
this
although now he challenges I don't even
understand what's going on here so this
is just weird
so in the meantime while I wait for
another opponent I'll pull up the chat
so what you guys are are asking have I
can marry me Ranke tome writes have you
considered getting a mouse sponsor I'm
not exactly I mean I've I've actually
used the same same same same mice for
for pretty much ever since I started
playing online um know if people can see
it but I just have some you know a
standard Logitech just a standard
cordless Logitech mouse it's a little
bit dirty obviously if you feel look
closely at it you can see that I've used
a lot but um but yeah I've used cordless
mites pretty much since I started
playing online I mean I've never I've
never gone for any fancy stuff so it's
just it's it's never really been
necessary for me I know there are a lot
of people use like optical mice or on
things along those lines but I haven't
and for me I haven't so I've never had
issues so the rook twirler writes your
hand your hand doesn't cramp up from
that Mouse yeah I've never had many
issues with that actually for the most
part I mean if I if I play for like five
to six hours and sometimes it does but
generally I don't have issues no I see
someone accepted a challenge so dulles
okay so dulles is ready to resume the
match so we'll see so here he plays a
slightly different set up I'll play out
5a Knight f6 and see what how he wants
to play this oh well let's take you can
take probably or you can play Knight g2
possibly all play Knight is six here
tonight now it kind of has to take or
else he lets me play Knight and c5 and
now now the night knights awesome as it
protects pretty much everything here
so 93 you know if you lose the fish ball
take and I know it's also in the chats I
think it was trust Bay said clean your
mouth yeah I sometimes I do right right
usually I don't even notice and I don't
forget I've also had this had this Mouse
for quite a while now I mean obviously I
was just in st. Louis as well so I'll
consider it at certain point in time but
right now I'm just focusing on playing
good shots more so than been cleaning a
mouse
it's a d5 probably helped take I'm
assuming all I'll take with the pawn and
then maybe is f3 not simple simple to
play for either side right now but I
think I'm okay here
three I'll play Bishop e7
so it takes I'll take
so let's say so he's gonna take on f6 or
not probably he will but I think I'm
okay here
okay so please Bishop takes e4 and stud
okay so now alright soo my should just
take on d4 but we'll see yeah
if I take on d4 he goes King jutsu and
then if I take on e4 and play Bishop e5
I think I'm okay I think it goes Queen
b3 I just go Queen d7 and if he doesn't
go Queen b3 I got d5 for my queen
so place Queen a four I can't play Queen
d7 oh I completely forgot about that oh
no I mean no I'm probably just lost that
I just completely forgot that I thought
he could do that um yeah that's gonna
that's gonna be a big problem so I'll
try to struggle on somehow and hope
against hope that I'm not just lost here
on the spot but probably I'm just just
completely lost
hopefully we're cafe
takes takes probably queen d3 probably
all just take on b2 again this this
should just be lost but you know you
never know what can happen
it is blitz after all so this would be
to work out for one and this is this is
really kind of bad hopefully queen d8 I
don't know why but something I just
start lagging quite badly so I don't
know what's going on exactly
but 94 yeah this is just gonna be lost
and I move over to I mean I'm probably
just gonna resign yeah there's not even
really a point I don't know why I
started lagging though let me see what
just happens I just know as I started it
became very very slow some way so just
give me one cycle to see what what's
going on but I think I'm done I'm not
gonna play dulles anymore because he's
he's being kind of annoying just like
heaps of boarding games any plays when
he wants to so if he if he avoids this
game then then I'm not gonna play them
anymore but if he wants to if he wants
to play both colors on then envenom can
play definitely
castle plays c4
don't really know what's going on it's
only I'm like really really slow I don't
know why this is really kind of annoying
[Music]
see why I'm so slow
okay so d5 high of three now it's in
speed seems flying again so let's see
okay so okay so a three Bishop c3
probably please ninety-four so I'm going
to take play Queen d4 here or just
simple it will simply Brooksie one or
just Bishop d3 I think Bishop b3 makes
the most sense so he takes I'll take he
plays Bishop g4 I'll just uh let's see
it so okay so if you take salt tank
plays like Bishop g4 I'll just take on
e4 and yeah I think who was it who wrote
that uh max that seems like stream lag
I'm not sure what the lag is but it's
not it's not a big deal at any rate so
I'll put B for making take the take the
bishop now if this base six probably be
five if takes on c4 I can just take the
pawns I've got a check here on c3 so
Queen off six so now the question is how
to proceeds so I think here I will
proceed with between d4 because now if
he goes bish basics I can just play b5
again or 95 this law both both are
possible so he plays Bishop a sec so now
the question is do I want to play b5
yeah I think I do and if you take so
I'll just take on half six and take on
d5 or just take on d5 right away in fact
and with this structure so he plays b4
snogging plant rook c1 which I think I
will
so now he takes on d4 I'll just take
back with the night so please be three
so he's trying just to do something here
right away but can't I just take on f6
and throw in a check and take a sex or
am I missing something here looks it's
the takes takes rook takes a6 take 6b to
92 or b8 I mean maybe it's just headed
for just another another another endgame
which is just gonna be like drawing or
something I mean this is this kind of
weird King g7 or k-6 and b2 then I
rotate so takes a 6b to 92 rook b8 and
then like an IB 1 rugby 5 rook b5 could
be an issue or a p5 okay to work c5
and anyway this looks leaves headed for
another ooh king of five what is king of
five that is not to move that I was
expecting however so now I can play I
can take and play nighty - maybe why
can't I just take just takes enough be
292 rook b8 and then somehow I feel like
with this king yeah he must play this
because now now as you're gonna see this
King on f5 is completely misplaced
so b2 now I take and then play rook rook
be one if Keaney for I'm gonna go King
up one enough rookie when I go Keaney to
in 92 and he's just completely boxed in
although maybe not maybe I just
blundered actually maybe not
I forgot that actually with this way he
is king c4 so this is gonna be tricky so
king c3 King b3 Knight c3 five now I'll
play E for g5 up lady sighs like king d3
and actually he right here I'm just
gonna win tonight's so much better and
black and can't progress with these two
pawns where they are on the board so
I'll play out for I'll take I'll take
play f4 don't Lee 905 and now King D for
iv6 Knight c3 and now I go 94 now I have
this this awesome night this is power
knight on e4 that that basically just
finishes him off here so all place oh
I'll play the same thing see if I can
see if I can get him with this again ci
wants to play this place c5 well this is
turning some kind of weird English now
so it's the so play Knight f6 oh I just
lied e5 here that might have been bad
but he pleased III just conservative
play h3 off my 98.9 t4
before I can play f5 I guess I think I'm
just gonna play e6 oh I don't know what
the point of e six was if I'm gonna let
him float like fish broth - now it's no
no I think I'm gonna take on e 2 because
now B 2 is hanging between you two now
I'll play off 5 and I'm basically try to
play along this diagonal so obviously he
takes I'll take please roof do you wanna
play 96 maybe 5 when I take take a plane
out of 7 take if you tasted the rook I'm
gonna go D 6 and now he'll probably play
work ft 1 but then I can just click
Queen c8 and sidestep everything now if
you all prima verde forks if he doesn't
take a pawn obviously the move won't be
executed so we'll see how he wants to do
here so
so what else is there so he he took with
the brook I kind of thought he might
play like this I mean he's gonna get
he's got this night b5 idea so I do it
to be careful but I don't think it's
sufficient here so I'm gonna take
he takes now I have 26 probably I'll
play point off three I so but again I
think it's not quite sufficient here so
he plays b4 okay so he wants to play c5
so if I take taking up something c5
takes takes rook c8 d seven I'm too slow
yeah I'm a little bit too slow so I can
play a five or I can just play push me
you saw in here getting all this take
he's gonna probably on take with the
pawn I would assume one you could take
with the bishop too I guess
although he takes to the bishop then I
probably take the knight so he takes
with that I'll play a six now you play
c6 all play Bishop da
and basically the point behind the a6 is
that I cover the b5 square so now he
can't he can't play Knight b5 because
I'm covering the square so he plays
Bishop c5 I'll play it's gonna be hard
to win this I have to admit I'm not sure
I can actually so I'll play rook b8 try
to do something so please Knight b7 no I
now I complete Bishop c7 though can III
I'll play this this might be quite
dangerous I have to be very careful now
so cleric b8 rook c8
this this could be very dangerous I have
to be very very careful here
so he has a 96 maybe he plays King D for
but now cuticle a bishop be 895 and
maybe I just have to force a draw here
with bishop see something so tonight's
before I just go Bishop d8 so I don't
really want to take a draw here but I
don't see anything better King out 7
Bishop d6 or Bishop d6 it's just it's
just probably it's just too dangerous
unless I can check on d8 but I don't see
it I mean I really don't see it here so
I'm just gonna although now he goes
night c4 and now I think wait Bishop d8
would be sweet what the 58 and now
he's somehow he's blundered now I just
he just wandered away the pot so a force
now I just taken and now he's now he's
losing no no this is definitely why it's
definitely losing here but now it's it's
more matter in our technique how I take
advantage of how I play against is a5
pawn to g4 I'll play King off 7 if 96 I
just take so I'm gonna play King ea and
now it's worth noting this Bishop is
also kind of trapped on B so it's a
little bit not trapped but it's stuck
and I can't do much so so it's okay so
there should be two a4 hopefully before
try to make it interesting try to play
something normal with b3 with I guess b3
and b4 having been thrown in and then
it's kind of weird but so plays a3 I'll
play Bishop C 1 T 500 play e5 and now
it's worth knowing this is kind of like
a front but there there was a pawn in e3
that I can just snatch here so play
Bishop e5
should be seven always take know this
castle I'll probably play d4 then I'll
play there should be two and I'm just
gonna go teeth ug5 Wow play d3 probably
hopefully g4 here I soon or Bishop g7
one of the two or just naive sovereign
okay so I'll play I'll play Knight d2
know maybe g4 Knight g5 or something 96
no he wants to play chief for obviously
so how best to combat that I'll just
play 94 I'll try and I'll try to force
him to simplify into something a bit bit
cleaner that's not so clear so I'll play
c3 and now probably he'll take I would
assume takes takes Bishop c3 Bishop g7
it's it's about equal I mean this is I
mean this isn't really what I want it
but it's it's a game at least so
probably he'll take probably but I'm not
sure probably there's a g7 I'll play
Knight e3 Knight f3 all this take
and we'll see how he plans plays so
checkmate one rights knock has
definitely tilted as opponent I don't
know if I tilted I mean just seems to be
playing strange stuff really that's
that's what it seems to be more than
anything so here I can take on p7 or I
can play work d3 I like rook to e3 more
it seems more logical to try and take
advantage of this bad pawn here on f3
so Bishop before I will take the pawn
because I always add Knight d6 coming if
King g7 in worst case I can play e5 but
probably all display broke up d1 and or
kini submerge d4 for example so he plays
castles so now I don't want to take the
pawn after you right away so here I'll
play rook F D 1 and now if you please
roof be it I can play Knight dat one so
now a - I'll take the pawn enough 3 and
my knight here is fine it has da de as
d6 multiple squares and the rook on a 3
is very nice - as it can put pressure on
f7 later on
so what are the questions of relevance
here um let's see so rap krishna is 24
daddy should start professional chess as
a career I think in general trying to
play chess as a professional player it's
very hard to begin with so if you're not
already up there by it if you're not
already a strong grandmaster probably by
the time you're about like 17 I would
say 1718 at the latest you you shouldn't
it's not a real consideration when we
put it that way so K so f5 I don't play
98 here if he takes on e4 I'll take on
our fate so actually I can cream with
that and just take 96 I know obviously
actually if he takes I can play with d4
oh I'm 51 so I'll just take the 95
I guess is e3 here
there's c5 I'll just take the pawn king
h1 and uh his before I completely
forgot about that move okay so that
wasn't full or I can play were q1 I
guess
King d6 but now I can get out of jail I
can play knight Knight f6 I'm shocked
and I mean I'm definitely gonna try to
flag now
although I probably won't be able to
because it's
well he's being very very slow again
like he's not being fast
he seems very very slow I don't know why
I mean I played him a lot at bulleting
she wasn't very very fast but he seems
very slow tonight fact he seems slow the
other night - actually so I I don't know
what's going on
so alright so score nine one right now
let's say so you can take with the Queen
I guess I'll just yeah I hold this take
with the night off night vision she's
seven some kind of weird maracas but
I've got the bishop on b7 right away
which should be a good thing so play
Knight f6 probably will play off three
although normally in term Roxy you don't
play h4 so please age five so you see I
think he's kind of on tilt or actually
he's playing strange moves someone I
have five now how best to play I can
take on c3 I think I'll just play simple
just take on c3 and play Queen c7 and
and just counts along and get out of the
way of any any nonsense it's a 97
clicking d8 of Queen h5 o play Queen e5
at night eh five here I can play Queenie
five anyway because these pawns are also
loose plays out for I'm gonna play play
Knight a5 I can play rook c8 why don't
want have a lot of good moves here I'm
gonna go broke g8
Oh a hearing light of night of five
against this probably wasn't the ideal
way to play this but I'll play rip g4 oh
and I just like 96 i-96 but rook out for
I guess and I'm probably okay but this
I've kind of made a bit of a mess out of
the side I need to kind of focus a
little bit
so micron rights
dubov is tilted like the Tower of Pisa
yeah maybe he is tilted at this point
but I mean he's been way too slow in a
lot of games like most people know that
I like to flag people but normally if
you reach the position with plenty of
time on a clock I won't I won't do that
um but he's he's been very very slow
throughout so I don't know I know it's
cuz it's later what's going on but he's
he's just been John really all around
very very slow so Knight a5 between d4
maybe I'll play e5 or just f6
maybe this f6 stop any mate thoughts on
h8 here with the Queen and also C 4 and
C 3 are quite weak to simply this Bishop
h3 so now I completely 5 if I wanted to
I don't know if I want to but if I
Queenie through Queen c4 looks pretty
reasonable 94 Bishop g4 is also
reasonable but I like he 5 I likey 5 it
makes sense and he can't go Queen these
6 but I can just take and take on g3 so
the place Queen d3 is nomina take and
I'm just gonna play this position where
I've just got I don't know what I have
I've extra something extra
wow it castles but now I could just take
and take on e4 and
I think it's just yeah just over so okay
so let's see so alright it's a next game
okay so okay so he's gonna keep playing
this g6 I'll play d4 take probably go
he'll play Knight f6 again I assume this
time he's not going to okay okay he's
gonna play this slightly differently
this time Oh Castle probably d6 c4 is
gonna play d5
okay so d5 c4 so I guess there's a
question who would I rather fight 10 B
besides Danny's or 1 Danny sighs maybe I
assume that's referring to Danny run CH
I'm gonna assume that's what it's
referring to
although I'm not sure I would much
rather fight against one one one
normal-sized Danny the 10/10 little
dance so I am threatening Bishop c5 here
not that I'll do it but it is there no
this clean 82 and if you play c5 I can
just take I'm hoping you blonde ruse up
but I don't think you will know it's a
little bit too good for that
so please b6 I'll play Queen B -
probably there should be seven then I'll
play like work after you want please see
if I right away Bishop c3 there should
be seven and now I'll play and play work
F do you want or I'll play work f d1
basically I want to keep the square
maybe for my bishop drop back to f1 at
some point so we'll see what you want to
do here so f d7 I'll play now I need to
think hopefully I can play Bishop b5 I
guess not crazy I'll just play Knight f3
so if there aren't any any questions
anything like that love you no sir work
d8 all take and I'm work d7 I play 95
and what he wants to go 94 fish about 7o
fish about 7 sorry but please show us
something in between up 7 high school
not good just a blackout complete
blackout who fun in some trouble boy but
I don't really have anything better so I
kind of have to go for it at this point
so I mean this is not very good
obviously but you never know
so we're cup seven I can play f3 if I
want to I don't really want to obviously
but I don't really have anything this is
really not very good to beginning us so
let's see so I played with you one
hopefully work takes off to f3 which
would be - I don't really have anything
as far as I can tell but I'm gonna have
to try it anyway and he's going to take
I'm gonna go king off one
probably yeah if you find a five I'm in
real trouble here so I can still play
King somewhere maybe can you - maybe
King you to Bishop d4 works c1 or
something or worth EU one maybe yeah cuz
I'm fish basics I can go king d1 I mean
this is pretty terrible but it might not
be just wha it might not be just lost
right away though
so let's let's see if he's gonna be here
so please Bishop seasick 6 so he's
planning to try out my queen my Kiki has
worked up to him would be too I
play like I don't know like Queen c1 or
something or King d1 maybe gonna go play
King d1 now let's see so plays Knight c3
King C 295 Queen c1 Bishop d7 I don't
know if I have anything here really I'll
play king d2 again I seem to be lagging
unfortunately this is kind of annoying
but d4 probably they'll take
mc1 king c1 as
now I'm some of there's too much lag
well on the bright side at least this
game on this game I'm just losing
fortunately so it can't be too upset
about that one but that was that was
annoying like at the end of that game
it's alright let's see one okay
ninety-seven probably be four again I
would assume or d5o play d5
ninety-two Sona place c6 here try to
chip away to Center a little bit now
I'll play off five left three I'll play
it's five
so now I place rook a one I'm gonna go
King h7 all that exchange the rooks here
if you want so I really want to change
his dark squared Bishop Civ I can so
please Queenie one interesting so you
really wants to just play like some kind
of endgame here I guess I guess that's
his his plan Queen c1 I'll play off for
now I might actually try and attack him
over here on the kingside because now
that without dark square Bishop it's
gonna be very hard from to attack over
here on the UH on the Queen side so 93
I'll play rook c8 Queen B - I'll play g5
so I am gonna so someone's gonna get
mated probably I mean on the I'm either
gonna meet him on the Kings side or he's
probably gonna crash on the Queen side
was still my Queen side does look like
it's holding so far it doesn't look like
it's it's that bad so take maybe you'll
take with the e pawn I guess I'm in but
here I can still clip b5 I think b5 bb5
he's gonna do some friend I also
completely four maybe even four actually
looks good I like you I like the concept
of e4 at least even if it's not a good
move I like the concept
tonight plays rook to you one so I can
play 95 probably okay so he wants to
take so maybe I'll just go III in fact
just ether and ignore completely and
next one I want to I really want to put
a knight on e5 like in a mover to now
and so far everything is holding so my
King here there's it's not really there
no role weaknesses so now I play ch4
which I kind of saw but I didn't
Tim strike me as being more really
dangerous I'm gonna go Brook GA he takes
I'll take Queen a 493 is queenie for aha
finds a good move
okay so now I'm gonna go have to be
careful now so let's see so he's
threatening what is he threatening so I
take on d3 for example he doesn't have a
threat I don't really want to take on d3
but I don't see anything better
Oh see he takes off like we not fade
bring my queen closer to this to the
Kings side trying to try and create some
threats on the G file here
so please 94 and I really don't like
taking on ah4 but I think it's probably
the correct way to play this not I can
play h3 to I can also just play Queen
out 6 I think I'm just one play Queen
out 6 on 1996 just 96 just holding
holding all the glue together so King f1
so trying to wrong with his King knots
of 96 i lot a night of five on h3 he
takes don't play rook e8 take the a file
here take the only open file on the
entire board although I did blond repeat
a c7 I'm lucky up Queen takes d4 here
now sometime sometime I'm still okay
here I don't know how but do I have E -
I think I do have itto and I'm rookie -
okay one rookie 164 turn in g1 I'll take
like Queen off one and I should just be
mating - my thing so Queen d7 king e5
and there is no perpetual here
okay I think I'll start trying to play
more normal shots now so let's let's see
let's see what I can do play III night a
three c4
see five d5o it please be 596 oh wow
okay so I was not expecting that before
okay I'll play
hopefully a night PD - and I'm gonna
have to play for efore at some point now
but maybe I'll just play Bishop d3 first
just to get everything on the ideal
squares first so a 5a player b1a4 ELLs
played b3 and basically I just want to
put this Bishop on this this long
diagonal okay - I'll play between c1
probably hopefully an IP d7 I'm guessing
and I'll play rook e1 Knight b6 I can
play rotate one but then he'll play like
some kind of weird something around
there
I'm not crazy about it so I'm just gonna
play h3 provide an IQ for I guess I'm
gonna play like night off one night g3
or night of one night III maybe also
just to see what he's what exactly he's
trying to play for so now I can play
work a one though ya know now I can play
work they won't cuz rook b2 he hangs a
bishop on e6 so now in a way he kind of
has to take on anyone
or does he or no he doesn't just beat
through his hand
oops oops oops oops
that was a mistake although I can maybe
still take yeah maybe they can take his
now if he takes on d5 I well I can play
e5 but I can also just play Queen c2 I
think because now if he takes can I just
take on d5 can i play II d5 and d6 and
I'm gonna go for it anyway I don't see a
reason why it shouldn't be possible so
Bishop c3 I'm going to take east six and
all his pawns are on the wrong squares
here so if he takes I'll take he's gonna
have to take I'm gonna take and I don't
know if this is good or not he is King
g7 I can play Knight g3 probably 93
Bishop up to King up to work up eight
Knight h5 this looks this looks possible
so I'm gonna play Knight g3 and see what
his idea is to play Bishop c3 no no no
Knight a5 King G 697 King off six is
nothing so I think I'll throw a shock
catch it now I'm thinking to put Queen C
1 here
please Bishop g7 correctly and now how
to proceed or is there a way to proceed
not sure there is I mean I might just
have to take and play some kind of added
game although thrive Queen e1 sorry I've
cleaning one shot sorry
so no I'm actually doing fine I forgot
that I have Queen e1 so now I will play
well I play Knight h5 maybe just night
as far as that when he takes out
cleaning woman shock and if he doesn't
then that this long diagonal is gonna
come into play either way it's okay
Knight a for enuf 6 I'm gonna play a
night each to his queen c3 Queen t1
probably and if he does something else
97 I'll 1084 I mean he's good and now he
gives me this Chaka gun this check is
always a killer that's just to shuck on
this long diagonal know I can play 96 if
I want to I think I'm just gonna play
like yeah why not
I'm gonna play 96 like Queen a7 takes
takes and something because here I am I
am up a pawn it's worth noting so
Queeny for we play 93 I guess
and now I kind of has to make a quick
decision so I'm threatening 98 and all
those pieces are there in a state of
flux the moment is to figure out what
he's doing right away so right so keen
h7 I'll clean 88 make c7 I'm now he's
getting really boxing here on the
queenside all his pieces are getting
stuck
so is that it no it's not it he wants
Bishop d3 I'll play you 685 he takes
I'll take with the Queen I don't have to
take with the Queen but we'll say this
this again is slightly dubious white
should be a little bit better here but I
don't see any reason I should be the end
of the world
so all right so make c3 Bishop e7 I'm
just gonna castle play Knight to d7 d5
I'll tape you tEEX I can probably take
but I don't see any reason to try and go
for complications makes more sense just
to keep playing simple chest now now I
can definitely take on d5 takes takes
what is it the point okay I call the
boss I call the boss I take I take I
don't understand what he's okay so 97 to
know if this f3 for example about
3.3 Queen c7 Queenie 896 is dogfish page
7 at the end so I can't do that so I
guess I kind of have to just take and
now if he really wants to be bold he can
maybe take h7 but that it's hard to
believe that could possibly work
so click h6 look c1 I'll play Queen off
for trying force and I took that square
here like h3
old climber right spork kid knock a stop
it let's go to bed
I feel like playing more and more why
not I mean if he won't if he's if he's
gaming he wants to play there's no
reason to stop playing so Rick's c7 I'll
play Bishop c6 try to trap this rook
here maybe like with Queen d8 or
something
perky one that's a good move I actually
didn't see that hopefully 97 and I can
take on c6 I'm probably just equalized
but I don't think he'll do that but
we'll see so it isn't so takes takes
and it's positions variable night afore
for example probably kills the entire
game 904-906 95 zone I'm referring to
and he played it naturally I mean it's
kind of hard not to play night afore
it's a simple move so unless I can do
something here on this back rank like in
the next like half mover or something I
mean I'm probably just gonna just gonna
make a draw-off quickly so let's see so
Queen B 3 I can play work D 2 here it
looks like it doesn't look like it loses
so G 3 you know how click Queen C 5
years Ricky eight
so I'll just play Queen d7 take complete
control this D file keep the rook on
keep pressure on these Queen side pawns
and now maybe here I can try to do
something I don't know like g5 maybe or
maybe Queen up five work f3 doesn't
quite work I mean I'm gonna go for I'm
gonna play g5 why not
so queen c3 now shot it's going another
Chuck
now if work f3 I've g4s
but kh3 Wow okay so King inch three I
don't have g4 anymore he's starting to
meet me now so I have to be careful I
could always play birth d4 and now I'm
trying to meet him in the one with g4 so
he plays g4 I'm gonna play h5 okay play
Queen d7
probably gonna play Brooktree three or
no if you want okay rook e8
Wow that was terrible that was really
bad
does he does he have like does he have
bad lag or something cuz it he just
seems to be extremely slow at the finish
every game and I don't really understand
why because I should have lost that game
I mean if you if you use maybe it wasn't
maybe it's on like a touchpad or
something because he should have won
that game I mean he really should have
hit about 5 seconds it wasn't that hard
to on win all my pawns and and promote
so I don't know what's going on with
dollies tonight hoping I could do -
maybe he'll play 8/3 here no I plays
Bishop c4 I'm gonna play like I'm place
c4 tried develop my pieces was d4 ok so
now I'll put a 3 and if you take time I
take as my queen now this is some kind
of weird like banco banco or bloomin not
blowing all this more like some kind of
banco sort of position but i don't
really understand what's going on
so it takes takes work a6 good move on
you want to play with b6 if I take so
please c5 here again now I'm trying to
take the pawn on b7
let's now let's see what's he gonna say
please we're k75 night chief five here
I really want to do something I feel
like there should be more than more than
just developing but I don't see it right
off maybe like night see for East's I'm
gonna play Knight to c4 I'll just play
Knight to c4 and try to develop fish b6
now I can play Knight g5 if I want to
but I'm just gonna castle because he by
putting the bishop on e6 he's he's
stopped himself from developing here
it's no employee for
so I assume he'll take defea and then
the game will continue um like east six
I can play d4 I mean II for efore is a
gambit move I don't really like it that
much so I'm just gonna play d4 he plays
Knight a5 I'll just click Queen Queen a
fork stuck in Queen c2
Bishop d6 Queen C 294 Point C for my
positions about equal again I mean I
miss my chance I mean probably I should
have been significantly better there for
a bit
but I missed the opportunity now I just
kind of to just play like a normal game
again so there should be four no I'm
gonna play 92 I'll take I'll take maybe
I'll play h4 I don't know actually
please b6 I can take if I want to I
don't have to but it makes sense just to
take and create a big center here so
this takes takes e4 and and play with
the center that I have because whites
play to h5 Andy is a king on e8 so he's
gonna have to play age four probably if
he doesn't if he if he intends step or
cancels so h4 uncle' g4 probably he'll
play age 3 lakh one no I've got g5 also
to dislodge this night from f6 it's a
night h7 and now I know I feel like
there should be something here there
really should be but I don't see it's
always play Knight f3 keep playing
so councils Queen three ropes c7 I'm
gonna play with you one I really want to
play g5 g sex if I can
oh he is rook see - yikes it's Queen b3
Quincy ate no I don't really want to do
this but I don't have anything better so
I'm just gonna exchange them we're gonna
reach some kind of and game I guess
Knight f6 but now I can well now I can
just take now directly e5 or do I take
on e6 I think I just are if I take on
each 60 takes on 84
so I played g5 Bishop e7 it doesn't
quite work I think I'll play e5 here
right Bishop e7 then I'll probably play
d6 although I did give them the trip g5
but Bishop g5 I'll clear up d1 and I'll
basically try to I've got these two this
D file maybe two to play with plate d7
no I didn't miss play this so I'm gonna
end up losing this d7 pawn unfortunately
I think maybe not
I've got weight work d4 he's gonna take
so yeah I kind of miss played this a
little bit I mean because Queen d3 is
rook d7 I'm just gonna have to play
moves now
and as he did he have a threat here I
don't see it threat right off so what
what do I do
play a five
and again I don't know what's going on
every time he gets a long time something
bad seems to happen um so I don't know
what's going on but um all right that
was strange okay so Dulles writes good
game so I guess that's it then I guess
he's done very strange very strange oh
he says not even a mouse so I'm guessing
it means he's not using a mouse or he's
easy using some kind of like touchpad or
something I don't know what that means
but not surprised that snot surprising
cuz he he seems to be extremely slow
tonight as I as I had mentioned so
what's it say who is there so I
challenged who I challenged let's see so
I challenged on gyro and Yakov will
either of them accept or not I'm not
sure if either than will accept so let's
see okay well I heard that sound so that
means someone just accepted tonight I
have three okay so on a play yard so
let's see what he wants to do play d4 c4
c4 okay when I have six probably he'll
play Queen before I would assume 94-94
is playable but it's a little bit
drawing b3 I'll play knight c6
which would be to look like queen bee
seven takes now I can take with the
Queen or or just take with the pawn I
think I'm just gonna take with the pawn
here this is pretty pretty dry as I said
before this is a very even position so
castle clear 51 probably six not a whole
lot to write home about so far so else
it's or if d3 I think I'll try Knight g4
try to get some Knight e5 in here trying
to try to mix it up a little bit so that
it's not just just a boring draw two
plays 94 Oakland 95 probably he'll tank
yeah probably he will sand clockwork d1
and yeah this is pretty pretty boring so
I'm gonna play like I'll just put my
bishop back on g7 be pragmatic to start
like Queen 86 rook d7 I look like queen
83 plays h4 I complained h5 I don't know
if I want to but I will because I always
have Queen B 2 so as long as I have this
clean b2 idea he's never on I'll take
now I can play Queen B 2 here as I was
pointing out still this even but I can
also just take well I'm just gonna take
the pawn I'm gonna get greedy here no no
here I cannot take another point here I
have to check on b2
and Queenie five and and now I'll see
what he wants to do because he's because
now that my queen is active I mean it
should be completely fine for me so I
just have to figure out the right way
the right approach now so I'm gonna
start by playing 8th I'm gonna try and
open up the this aid file so I'll
probably play a four I would assume but
no he doesn't so I'm gonna play it now
I'm gonna play a four if work to to I'll
play a takes b3 906 King h8 I should be
fine
or should I be fine and actually should
I be fine maybe I'm not fine maybe three
night of six night of 1688 night eh five
fish page six night of six queen of four
okay I've got to see if he has any ties
that they're good for him I'm not seeing
it the night of 1688 night h5 Bishop h6
tonight a6 queen of four I'm not seeing
it so he either has it or he doesn't and
that's just how it goes
so any other question guys in the
meantime tonight a 16 a j9h 5 he's gonna
play night at 5:00 hell publish page six
I mean if he hasn't he has it good for
him I really I don't see it though
and again this aid files so critical for
my work because my works are so passive
here on a fade in a that I really need
to try and do something so faculty has
been thinking for a while is definitely
a good sign
it means that he hasn't spotted anything
obvious so plays Knight f6 against now I
think Queen of four is the right move
yeah Queen afford looks right just
because now you can't move the Queen off
without hanging as night its Queen
protects tonight but my queen also
protects the bishop so if you please
work G for I think I can take on a to
even but I could just take and I don't
see a meet here that's the good news I
don't see a mate but now okay so you
place it like this now now though I can
start to slowly unwind I'll play Bishop
e5 because now I have okay one next move
now I'll play Bishop d4 and now he's
just in trouble because now I've got big
problems
so alright so that's a good start again
so round two again something solid
simple d5c for probably night bd7 take
93 probably 94 oppa 95 take sticks and
they'd see five we'll play Bishop C to
96 I want to play 92 just to stop him
from playing D 5 D 4 and I also want to
include like at 4 F 5 so now I'm gonna
go out for plays f5 now I complete G for
maybe be very bold why not people let's
go for it let's see what he has here so
take something I see 3 basically I just
want to take this and also now it's pawn
structures a little bit a little bit
loose over here on the kingside I mean
everything's just kind of hanging by a
thread now so now I can play f5 if I
want to I don't I mean I'll just play it
why not why not why not just play it
just do it I think that's the that's how
the saying goes
Knight g5 I'll take and now I'm turning
to play like each for you 6 off 6 I mean
this is really kind of just odd goalie
so I can play h4 night of 7 e 6 and
that's just GG kind of so he plays 94
this still is extremely ugly for block I
mean for example I think I can just take
and even display like Queen e4 and now
not only am i attacking the rook but now
I've got this diagonal too so if he
moves to Brooke I just play off 6 and
it's game over
in fact I think the game is just over
here I mean takes off six and oh no I'm
threatening need on this diagonal - it's
like everything's hanging here so jeez
six I can can't I just take the rook I
can even just play e6 probably yeah why
not just with a handle like cruel er oh
it's time for me to be cruel to him and
just punish him now
okay so round three how do I want to
play this yeah I'll play the same line
again
Castle if be three I'll probably play d5
so here I'll give them a chance to plea
for and get his morality side up
please e for Oakland 96
there should be three I'll play Queen c8
yeah I see someone just made made the
reference the legendary Mortal Kombat
phrase which what's the phrase punish
him now punish him
it actually saw punishments finish him
isn't it finish him finish him
so e6 probably can take again and we got
the same kind of pawn structure very dry
very boring but he plays Queen d2 it's
not if I play d5 doesn't quite work 97
or how do I want to play d5 I can always
play d5 I'm fine but I want to somehow
create something here so I think I'll
just play work c8 he's gonna play workup
do you want to let's play a six cut the
b5 score off from his knights so it
takes I'll take back with the rook
Bishop g5 now he wants to take maybe or
not take I don't know but I'm gonna play
rook c8 at any rate if he takes I'll
take and basically I'm creating I'm
gonna create pressures that I'd be five
at some point in conjunction with this
diagonal so takes takes takes now I
think I just take I can play we'll see
seven as well
the rook see something might be
interesting actually um then it goes
Queen d3 be 592 and it's not enough so
I'm just gonna I'm just gonna take and
play simple chess
so sleeping trying to ask the questions
is does he cara of a stream schedule um
at the moment I don't I think it's very
hard in general to have a set schedule
because for the most part I'm playing I
still am a professional player I'm
competing a lot of tournaments and
because of that there usually are so
many tournaments going on that it's very
hard to have have any kind of real
routine unfortunately
thrifty - I can play Bishop g5 maybe
then he goes King F - but I'll try it
anyway see if he bought it seeing he
might wander without four and he oh wait
but then if I Tiki is King f3 oh no oh
that was unfortunate I thought he just
wondered the pawn on e4 I thought it's
being so clever and so smart but of
course and I was just being an idiot so
ok so if I played g5 f5 rookie for f6
Bishop f8 that looks interesting and
promising so I'll play g5 King out three
and now I'm gonna play 4k 3 laughter now
he's Keaney 4 so I played Bishop c5
Knight g4 h5 Knight f6 qg7 Teague's he
has three Bishop d4 what to do what you
do I'll play h5 here try to try and just
muddle everything in complicated just
take away the square from the from the
night
- guys rook c2 all throw in another
check
kimchee seven I mean I'm probably going
to try and flag him but I might have
some walks g4 it's gonna move to move
the King Bishop g5 f-16 king she's six
out he's six rookie four is very strong
so he does play a few six will play rook
before although he doesn t sub in here
which no e7 rookie five ropes a three
takes I was take King out to probably
king of two rookie five and I'm just up
a clean pond hopefully I won't have to
flag in this game that's never the goal
but sometimes it happens b3 I think they
can take here I think the Sun game is
just winning because now I can just play
e5 e four and his night is just terrible
so King c3 I'll play King DC 5 can be 5
and now he's kind of in a bad situation
because now I can just play Bishop d2
and I think I just pushed the pawn
straight to e1 ok
round 4 fight
so so far a pretty normal gun probably
working eight or maybe E or just e6 I
guess
yes round four fight fight fight
I don't know why I just said that anyway
okay so e4
now I can play Knight d5 I think I will
play Knight e5 and when he takes all
this take with the C pawn yes and of
course for those who who weren't sure
yes it is uh obviously it's a reference
to a street fighter that goes without
saying one of the best games of all time
for anyone who for anyone in the know
that's one of the greatest games ever so
Rick Rick see I'm gonna play h4 try to
play for h4 h5 play a three okay he's
gonna force me now by playing like this
it probably works he's seven I'll play
rook c1 Brooke FC one and he's gone up
play Knight c5 and caught me off right
away because I if I get if I get a piece
to c6 he's in real trouble
finally I can just take just takes
Knight c4
if Knight b3 I'll play Knight takes b6
and I'll hit them bishop in the night so
rook f8 I think I can just take I think
I can just Chuck I think I can just play
95 knocks move actually King 18-inch 795
this looks awesome
well if we're gonna have a conversation
about Street Fighter that's that's for
another day when I'm when I'm on my on
my own stream but we cannot you can't
have discussion about the various
version Street Fighter 4 also but for me
growing up with Street Fighter I mean
it's it's takes me back to the old days
the old old days the good old days I
think most people like to refer to it as
perk be a tricky one although here is
rook b8 maybe so I might have done
something wrong here but here I think I
can just take on c5 maybe rook c5 clean
up - I don't get it
we have to king h1 rook b6 rip cc1 or
work c7 shock so he's gonna take rupees
6 or not no he's not wait what
but now I can just take the rook will
chop King h6 okay what is going on here
so he's trying to play for a perpetual
so okay how to stop a perpetual here so
Queen c8 is a weird we need 14 h3 Kingi
123 Queen g2 does not work Brooksie -
takes King g1 does not work Queen 7 to
draw work h5 t h5 I have nothing work g5
takes Bishop g2 Queen h4 I have nothing
Queenie 17-inch Queen d7 rook F to work
h5 g a5 I'm gonna try let's see what
let's see if it works or not
I think of the worse I've got a draw
here so he's gonna go rook F - obviously
unless he's not but yeah he's gonna go
work up to so I tracked he's gotta take
so let's see so King there Chuck Chuck
Chuck I don't think I have enough here
to win but maybe I waiting g7 wait now I
check I'm not sure maybe I'm winning
here after Queen d8 so yes ago King h7
now I Chuck he takes I play Queen d7
Chuck this might be winning actress or
not Chuck King g6 rook Jiwon and rook F
1 I take and I'm winning and I'm winning
and actually rook f1 I also have Queen
b6 Chuck - and that's all she wrote
so let's see so I see someone wrote a
funny comment they said how come someone
says a look at the imbalances buddy card
just says all the lines sometimes the
lines are more important than than the
imbalances let's make this interesting
so d5 okay so I'll play a 693 I'll play
there's a d4
it's Bishop d2 interesting interesting
move I'm gonna take and a castle and I'm
I'm not so sure what what what Yaroslav
is doing here again he's gotten himself
into another position that's not not
really quite what you want here so
Bishop d3 I mean I'm gonna take he's
gonna take obviously with the bishop I'm
gonna throw on a rook e8 shock Wow
dc3 okay so I'm gonna Chuck take he has
two bishops here bishops cannot be
underestimated but with this pawn
structure it's a little bit hard just to
see any kind of attack really working
although it could I mean he's gonna get
chief for now maybe I should maybe I
shouldn't play tonight knight Knight f6
but at anyway let's see what I can do
here so g6 h4 is pretty dangerous
potentially I could just play d5 just
play simple moves and I think I will
basically I'm just gonna try it I'll
give him this h7 pawn but now at the
same time he's his pawns are slightly
overextended here so I'll play Knight d7
Bishop g4 g6 probably and I think I'm
okay here basically the point is white
spawns are not overextended and there's
not going to be any quick like pawn pawn
rush down the board so even though I
give back upon white white is
compromised the pawn structure
so there's your imbalance man there's
your imbalance okay so
so oh I see black Pope is shown up again
oh oh I don't know well I give him a
game tonight or wait till the next next
time
not sure anyway we'll figure it out
another time but I see black Pope right
who's your uh who's your favorite what
player did you play in Street Fighter um
they're a couple characters I mean I was
never an expert at the game so um wait I
just love Bishop h5 there I think I did
anyway I was never um the greatest
player in the world at Street Fighter so
on Queen d7 maybe Queen d6 also maybe
just 97 96 h4 pretty ugly stuff going on
here so maybe I'll just take take rookie
3 yeah I think I've got it like gamble
now I've got myself into a really bad
position so I'm Boyd Pope asked me like
who's my favorite character now if I
take I think I'm just going to take on
e3 who's my favorite character a street
fighter
my favorite character by far was or not
favorite character but the only
character that I was particularly good
with was uh was bison I think he was the
he was my best character by far this is
decent with some other characters I mean
I was ok with dhalsim never never great
but I was relatively decent with dhalsim
so queenie - i'm takes keaney to Queen
see - keenie one king keaney one f6 age
for work a chain I don't see it so I'm
gonna try and hold hope that I get lucky
here on hold yeah my favorite player was
uh was bison though bison and I play
occasionally played with dhalsim but I
wasn't a top level player so Dalton is
obviously a very difficult character to
play with him if you if you're really
good your high high high school player
he's probably the best character overall
but um but I wasn't that so obviously I
played shots not street fighter
professionally so so he was my best
character by far but okay let's see
Queen g4 rookie tier it worked you won
I'm gonna have to go King f8 94 probably
and there's probably some kind of
Perpetual or something here after
- 194 maybe that's just winning Queen
shaking some takes checking G - Queen
Chu for now if he doesn't have meat here
because of where all his pawns are I
might actually just be better or not not
even just like worse but I might even
just be flat-out better so root G - 27
because this Knight is a monster and he
really needs to find a way to exchange
Queens if he can
so we're there I'm gonna just grab a
pawn we know for owes to King g7
and here I don't even know why what a
night in a pond for the rook so I'm
actually doing really really well
hearing and since he has no time I'm
just gonna understand eyes
it's time for more flag events flag
events and here come the pawns - so
silver cage - I'll play were caged five
to stop them from doing anything over
hearing out you know that just the BNA
pawns are just gonna roll down the board
and boom it's just all over so alright
so it looks like yarrow has left the
room so who else is there to play maybe
I'll play vanishing dragon or can be get
her I'm on someone whoever's whoever's
planning
so let's see so there's some other
questions bulletproof ID says did you
watch Game of Thrones yes I did I did
watch Game of Thrones I actually
Washington advanced and since up so it
was leaked I was able to get a copy of
it ahead of time and watch it saved me a
Sunday evening from from watching it I
wasn't that thrilled by the episode I
kind of was hoping for something
different I mean they've been playing up
that old John and Daenerys relationship
for some time I was kind of hoping that
once obviously everyone knows they're
related but hey whatever whatever goes
so I was hoping I was hoping for
something a bit different but I have to
say the the dragon dying and then
turning into like I guess you call it a
white dragon or dead dragon or whatever
you call it almost pretty cool I don't
know what's gonna happen though I'm kind
of kind of interested I mean I'm I'm a
oh I'm sorry guy ruin it for everyone
but isn't it like it's Tuesday isn't it
everyone should watch the episode by now
isn't it isn't it Tuesday it's Tuesday
it's Tuesday come on come on you guys
what what do you want me to say it's
Tuesday
it was Monday like I could see feel
being angry with me but it's Tuesday you
guys that you guys got to watch it come
on come on it's Tuesday it's been two
nights it's Tuesday right Tuesday or
Wednesday or something
no it's Tuesday so anyway so what's
what's going off master man is he here
or not here am i lagging who's lagging
somebody's like I don't know who I guess
he's like wow he's really like huh so
surprising
it's a d5 Hill pros place 85 interesting
so I'll take probably he'll take I'll
take take on d2l play Knight c3
I'll just take and play Bishop d6 97 h3
Knight f6 95 will take takes with the
Queen off click Queen d5 takes 95 see
497 is what I'm going to do play for or
I'm gonna play a 5 no in a castle long
and basically I'm just gonna try and
play against these these weak pawns he
is he has the bishop pair here so it's
not it's not trivial but it's a c3 on I
played Bishop e6 so that he can't just
play c5 and get rid of get rid of these
CC pawns fish rough one and now I know I
need to think I can play I think I'm
just gonna play work HEA it maybe try
for e5 with this with the with the pin
along the D file some to file to h6
given the exchange he wants to take it
probably he should not take it but he
might he probably will take on f6 is my
guess I for now I'm gonna play like ok
so he wants it so you can play c5 here
try and try again play against these
pawns because one weakness here is that
all might not all my pawns but most my
pawns here on dark squares so because my
pawns are on dark squares he's got these
pawns on light he's got these these
pawns on light squares a foreign c4 in
particular that are very very weak so d
c5 I'll take and like here the only
weakness that I really have in the
position is on f7 at the base of the
pawn chain so I play h5 try to get it to
h4 probably is not gonna let me get it
there but I'll try nonetheless so rook
e8 takes I will
like King takes just so he has to go
King off to and protect this pawn on g3
I'll go King c7 probably he'll play
Bishop e2 but I don't know for sure but
the point again is that White's pawns
are weak my pawns I mean I created this
weakness on h5 potential that maybe I
shouldn't have but okay so if I play
Brooke b8 takes Bishop e2 takes takes
Bishop b3 King III a4 a3 I'm probably
too slow so I'm gonna go work a8
there should be two now I'm gonna take
the pawn and we're gonna see who's gonna
be faster here I will hold this up c2
since work eight one I'm going to push
it for I'll take on f7 of course
or hopefully Bishop d1 interesting
bishop d1 I'll tape say three play what
will I do I'll play a to h4 h5 h6 yeah
so I can push the pond to a to king d7
Kimi 7h 5 no I'm gonna go play like be 5
play rook a3 is there now what I'm just
gonna play King f8 fact I don't know why
I did this it's kind of stupid cuz now
he's gonna go like king of five
now this again this is gonna be a draw
but it's time for time two flags on the
time to flag someone and in fact now
he's just gonna lose cuz his King maybe
he's not knows king e4 still probably a
draw although now he's just lost
position is this this is not actually
losing but there's no way he's gonna
draw this and now this is a well known
King and pawn endgame
I'm game just you got the opposition on
you won
which would be seven I'll play d4
probably he'll take I'll play 92 or
night f3 anyway
graphs great graph e^x what rights knock
as a savage um I know I'd rather be a
hound than a savage personally but
assuming you get the reference that is
castle
d 6 what to do do I think I'll just take
off CSX and take on take on g7
and I don't really want to take on
seasick so I'll just play Knight c3 I
mean I could have just taken the night
giving it he could give him double pawns
again and just played another position
but and he's gonna force me then I'm
gonna do it
so I lick Queen before and we'll just
play another endgame I think or not
maybe I'll play Queen e2 and try a trick
and listen 94 at the right moment so
please Queen e7 I'll play e4 basically I
want to play like rook e1 a4 a5 all
kinds of stuff so f5 I could play rook
e1 then he goes off or or I could just
play out for myself I like playing out
for just so I can get the knight in any
four and then I can check them along
this long diagonal after Knight takes e4
server k e8 I'm gonna play Queen d4 if
he goes clean up six now I'll go e5
because now he's hanging upon an a7
so defea so I see someone mentioned
someone mentioned they need to they need
to buy me a new Mouse well next time I
do it next time I do do a broadcast on
my own channel someone wants to donate
like 50 bucks or a hundred bucks or
whatever so I can buy some high-end
high-end Logitech mouse then then go for
it I don't actually know what the best
best mice are these days I like I said
I'm a pretty simple person I've almost
always used just the just standard
cordless but I'm always open open to
trying something new
hi I'm Logitech doesn't have to be loach
that could be another brand - I mean I'm
not well-versed and uh what what the
best mice are these days there was a
time when I paid a lot of attention to
that but it hasn't I haven't really paid
attention to that and quite a while
anyway back to the game it's completely
lost for black because basically I'm
just up upon my night is awesome and I'm
and I can also potentially just run my
app on down the board and also black
spawns are not going anywhere so
strategically block is just just lost
here kingi it I'll play c4 because now
he can't go to e4 cuz then I'm gonna get
a fork on the Queen and the rook from 96
so now he's gonna have to go back to f7
for maybe he'll just resign yeah he
could just resign - so okay maybe so
let's see so maybe now I'll try and play
some bullet if anyone's around I don't
know if I'm on wants or if mom wants to
play maybe doesn't want to play or not
if the mom doesn't want to play okay
maybe I think now maybe for just for the
next like 3040 minutes I'll just play
just just send me challenges everybody
if you want to play and I'll just I'll
play you guys so I just sent some
challenges V some rights Amon has a
dinner with yes it's Tuesday night and
then Tuesday night I mean like Friday or
Saturday that's fine but I mean on
Tuesday night I'm on to be focusing on
trust and getting as a studying and gang
as she untile rather than entertaining
dinner guests so let's see so who wants
to challenge me I mean I like I said I'm
gonna play just I think I'll just play
play everyone now so I'll open it up a
little bit
so let's see so okay so who wants where
the challenges let me let me reload the
page you'll see just to make sure okay
so okay so let's see so who's who's out
there who's out there
worthy challenges no I'm not seeing
challenges right now oh there we go okay
I just closed my challenge come on so
okay I'll start opening it up a little
bit if you want to play me on just
mention your name here in the chat and
all I'll try to I'll try to play
everyone's that day if they mention what
their name is on chess Kong because
otherwise I might feel like 20
challenges to not know who's who
tonight u6 Bishop III on a place c5
probably d5 maybe maybe castles this is
reasonable to might be three I'll take
put a play knight c6 turns into some
kind of like there's some kind of
Sicilian like a pawn something like b6
instead of 86 but something like e 686
makes it pawn
directly b6 but if he's gonna make me
play any six well I'll play a six
unfortunately Bishop c5 is not a good
move normally I would be fine but here
I've got six now now what's dropping a
piece but normally would be fine if I
couldn't play off six would be a
completely normal move so GM moves GM
moves you're gonna get the next game so
you will get the next game jam moves
Bishop e3 I'll take play 95 next
as you can see - I'm gonna throw on a
chalk I'll tick take on a three just
exchange pieces I'm simply up a up a
piece here so I might as well exchange
like 25
with do you wanna play d5
came out for I'm just gonna castle kept
my King out of the center I'll just take
take
and now there's just night a four-track
this nasty four with the king of the
rook so now and this the rest really
isn't going to need explanation to just
pick up everything
maybe I'll starting pre moving and a
situation where I really should not
pretty move
let's check me so all right so where is
GMOs where she ominous okay I'll play
graphics for since since I since I see
the challenge showing up how to do is
hopefully a night it's five something
different
unusual try and take take this fish gone
out for take on a four I'll click Queen
b6 here tak deform v2
take probably go castle I'll take b2 why
not it's a free pawn it's always better
to be greedier than not greedy that's
that's an important thing to know in
chess always be greedy unless you lose
materials course like getting a queen
trapped or something like that but might
be 356 now I'm attacking both these
pawns
five that's a good move that's that's
that's a very good move trying to trying
to open up the center I like that that's
good move
so unfortunately f6 I mean positions bad
but I like this up five I like f6 I mean
this is a good way of trying to play the
position now though now that I flick
weensy turning my queen can come back
and take on g7 and protect everything so
all in all in all in let's see so I like
the style the H is silent I can take I
can play King h8 would be a party-pooper
because Canyon sure that's fine I just
seem to see if King takes h7 actually
works or does not work that's all I'm
trying to figure out takes Knight g5
King e6 Queen g4 clean up 1640 new six
name 1785 h4 King g4 why not if he has
if he hasn't brilliant made good for red
this could be one for the for the for
the for the record books but we'll see
maybe not
okay so here he goes ask for but now the
problem enough for is I think I can just
move my queen off like d8 now the
problem is white doesn't have any mate
sprouts and it's writing work a chain
it's a queen g3 good move so now I can
then go king of six and I think I'm just
escaping his 90-94 now I go king 787 I
go kini 7m and now I've escaped now
there's no meat and why it's just Y can
take take my rook obviously but but no
there's no meat and I've got two pieces
for whites work here on anyone
so it takes the Queen takes outfit
someone just a meet in 27 mist
I assume someone's trying to be funny
but if they aren't let me know today I
didn't see him eat
Queen h4 f6
so now you see father clipped me a chick
is try to exchange the Queen
and here unfortunately I can just world
these pawns straight up the board or I
can roll these pawns straight up the
board too
so here I'm going to use both my pawn
majorities and queen pawns here and
queen pawns here
and now I'm going to use my pawns here
in the center and
and okay so all right so now I'm gonna
play a G word few moves since I promise
in the game
I don't see GM moves
they don't see gymnast okay I think I
want to play Fisher fishery done fishery
fishery Fisher you saw sorry Fisher I
keep thinking oh there should be a six
interesting Okinawan IPD to the e for
takes takes base I think this bishop on
e6 a slightly misplaced
push great six bishops see - it's gone
I'll play King off one work the phones
possible - but I for some reason feel
like heaven I came out off one don't ask
me why
sound try to attack him here on the on
the King side
it's rook e8 I'll go country to play h5
for Kitsch one keep trying to put
pressure here alright if he i'll take so
you place FG 6 now I'm gonna no I'm just
going to double the rooks on the H file
actually first time play a fourth sin I
might have some Bishop e3 and something
on this diagonal - so you can dominate
all the diagonals like if I've got the a
3f a diagonal and the beat one h7
diagonal and they can get a rope th one
Black's just completely busted
so Queen d7 play I'll play rakesh one no
now I've got me to Knight g5 here like
this is this is really really bad for
black I think this is just lost in fact
there are many ways to play this what's
the simplest way I don't know it's just
the simplest but I like it so I'm gonna
play g4
Queeny seven just going to play like I
can play a four here for example I could
even just probably just take the pot but
Bishop c1 seems like the simplest way to
play this it's at this page six now I
can take I mean pretty much anything
should be winning here I think it's a
matter of how I want to do this I can
play it off or I think I'm just gonna
take I think he6 Bishop c1 is not so
clean so I'm just gonna take and play
rope g3 clean up four and now I'm gonna
take I just a lot of 24 I realized which
could be a slight problem but I think
I'm still winning anyway except cheese
sobbing and now I'm threatening work h8
- so we're catching g8 Queen it's just
game over so I think this should just do
winning 295 or catch aids
so let's see what he wants to do this
time so all right
tonight a three this would be for this
would be three night of six mean to d5
see what he wants to do here give you
five of the Queen d5 probably little
castle Bishop c3 are all distinct right
away
exchange the Queen's most likely I'll
probably go play 95 maybe not
oral let's play this way I could have
played an IP d7 first but didn't really
see the point so clean off three I'll
take play like knight c6 now maybe it's
Bishop b4 here which I kind of for some
reason for God about and I just blunder
completely just blunt blunder for no
reason it's not gonna get it done
more action now I just love c4 poof Oh
terrible yikes
yeah that's pretty bad let's see if I
can somehow salvage this
just about four I'll play purchase six
seven probably worked these seven and
can be seven try to get these pawns
rolling somehow someday somewhere
maybe now I have some chances of because
now he's now I lost the f3 pawn for
starters now I've got two pawns
it's a four pawn is week two and I've
got these two connected passers now I've
got three pawns I'm clear okay three
hitch six can be five okay fair enough
let's see three because now if he takes
I go can you see for in situ
waitwhat fish about four or
and now it's getting interesting this is
getting really interesting okay now but
now I can take and put like rookie for
an age five match for an hour before now
I might not be I may be winning this
actually
now this is just losing is just
completely lost for white because f6 I
can play Oh a no I can't play work a
four oh shoot oh I thought I was just
winning this oh that's terrible
now that was pretty bad too in rookie
one shock I guess
and after he decline that draw I'm gonna
try and flag him
and there you go alright so moving on to
the next game next game normally I would
give them a draw but after he decline
that draw like 10 moves 10 moves into
the game no mercy no mercy for Fisher is
all
pigs probably be c5i please 95 okay wish
me to know now I've reached a pretty
pleasant position I've got like night of
five coming probably he'll take on d2
I see fate just wrote a fine comment
when I offer you a draw you take it or
live to regret not taking taking it I
get very angry if my draw requests are
declined good to know good to know Queen
before probably f6 work to c1 this is a
pretty good position for me here he's
got this isolated pawn I've got the two
bishops against this Bishop at night and
I'm contesting the C file too
so all in all this is looking pretty
good for me so flip Bishop g4 here
trying to force try to tickle and force
him to give me the C file now he's just
completely giving me the C file he's
still got this week pawn here on d5 so
everything's looking very good now so
Queen d6 so now I have to figure out how
best how to take advantage of his arm of
the problems in this position of black
hat so after he's one move I don't
really like after I think I'm gonna play
b4 here try to take with a c5 score so
that I might have a 3-2 kick the night
from efore so please b6 logical
move and play h4 now if you goes Bishop
c4 I can just take the bishop on c4
because I know tonight will be hanging
on e4 at the end of the line
Queen e7 so he really wants to go Bishop
c4 bad lace no I'm here I think after
your last night g3 so it could be a
little bit careful here I'll just play
a3 pragmatic move Bishop to c4 I'll play
this left three cuz now I'm turning to
take on e4 now it's bishop everything's
all everything here is a little bit
loose so I'll play rook d1 try to take
advantage of this D file so please
rookie eight I'm gonna tickle them with
h5 to maybe get h6 so if these pawns
become very weak with the diagonal so
you plays h6 crack play and now I've got
to figure out how to proceed so I think
I'm gonna play Bishop g4 maybe maybe I
can take advantage like Bishop a5 Bishop
g6 or something like that for example
but now
f3 does not make sense nor does Bishop
f5
well this retreat militia back to f3 and
now I've got to figure out something so
I take on e4 Queenie for 2007 Queen c2
Queen d4 over p4 so I think I'm okay I
think I think I think I can grab this
pawn oh wow he takes a de for that I was
not expecting but there will be no draws
today for you mister yourself or as or
as the saying goes from the from the
from that well-known episode of Seinfeld
no soup for you so I think that's gonna
be my saying for Fischer Sol no draws
for you although I might not be able to
avoid it unfortunately yeah which is
kind of annoying
I'll try off three
there should be two that is a move but I
think now can't I go like rookie one and
now rookie one's no good
maybe rook d2 she got three King King f2
and I think I'm actually doing well here
now because now this pawn on Jesus to
become actually a very big strength
because now like now I now I control the
complete d file there so now I'll take
there should be six I'm going to play E
for so that there's no bitched about
five different g6 you go Bishop d4 well
here is rook da no then I have Bishop c5
they get Bishop c5 bish buffeted so I'll
Chuck I want to play like now for lost
Bishop e2 is going to play work d6 try
to put pressure on it's a a sexpot
basically try and tie him down to
everything so he plays f5 so I can play
e5 I can also just take I think I'm just
gonna take the pawn and now those pawns
become very strong so now I'm gonna go
visit d4 because now I've got checkmate
and one now I think row k7 should be
winning but I don't trust you know so
I'm gonna go King III and just work a7
next move okay no four
t7 no I'm gonna take and I've got this
rough six track and jisub no Chuck play
e5 and now I've got rookie southern
coming as well and that's that's all she
wrote again so okay so let's see it's a
p6 Knight c3 e6
there should be four probably Bishop d3
again I would expect maybe not then I
have six maybe e5 here or hope like we
need to okay
u5 probably he'll take again you know
we're gonna have the same same wine so
Bishop b2 Queen h5 I guess I'll Premila
Queen e2 just in case he moves the
knight or something so Castle take I
assume hopefully Queen takes as he did
before I just have to cope with a better
better setup
okay please g f3 okay so now I will play
how will I play here I think we'll play
Knight d7 make a logical move first and
then figure it all out later so h4 I
don't know what h4 actually accomplishes
but it's a move I think all this castle
on here weird as it looks it has some
purpose to it I think so what'd I just
do yeah
okay all right so we're DG once now he
wants to take g7 or play worked g5 so if
I take and play Knight d5 if I played
cheese 62 Scott rook g5 so maybe I
should just Chuck the pawn apply like
each sex ed work ht8
Murph g3 but now I'm gonna go Bishop d6
force him to give me this open G file 94
I've got to figure out how to play so I
take he's got Queen takes c4 maybes got
some some Queenie its stuff for
something so I'm just gonna play King d8
not though this move makes much sense
but it gets the King out of chucks maybe
at some point I can take on e4 but this
is this is hard to play I mean this is
not a good position
c4 I'm gonna go King e7 maybe I'll play
c5 if I get the chance and then this is
this is pretty hard to play I'm in
trouble here that's that's for sure so
play e5
so this would be for anomaly now I'm not
king DA maybe clip rook e8 Bishop c2 and
I'll go king d8 cuz when he takes I'll
take on d4 Queen d3 probably rookies 6
and I'm trying to fight here I'm trying
to fight it's not easy but I'm trying to
fight so Queen before but now I get a
point off three and now I've got some
hope
now there's definitely some hope those
clicking c8 sidestep any tricks on the D
file before so he wants to go Bishop f5
I'm guessing so how'd it how do how to
avoid any nonsense hopefully a queen to
four no Bishop a5 now and the Queen
protects maybe I something I want one
was fourth rank too
so f3 ith by 5 fighting fish about five
I think I have to go Queen h3 really not
what I wanted to do but still not not
not lost yet
so please Bishop b4 and now I know I'm
in trouble
no no I've got to find something
instantly like Queen h4 bish about five
I'm just gonna go for this give him
about five and play King b7 and
hope that I can hope against hope that
somehow I can survive this onslaught not
gonna be trivial so play Queen age look
like Queen eats five I guess six yeah
that's too much ya know that was
unfortunate no it was really unfortunate
okay no more mr. nice guy time to spank
him
and six fish for gonna be 693 937
point out three Council for maybe
they'll play g5 maybe not
hey guys I'll take I'll play Queen shoot
three takes takes take five h3 I have
six now I'll just like I'll play a four
there should be three one
like 94 or something try to do something
here in the center it's a castle it
would be for pleasure b5 maybe try out
this fish bump c6 Queen b3
so here black has big problem services
King has very loose no I can take I
think I'll take c6 I'm played b5 I think
this makes more sense you know just what
to do I'll play Knight takes b5 does d6
is loose now - like I'm threatening work
takes off supplement potentially because
that night takes d6 is let's ride and
I'm king of the Queen and everything
she's hanging plays 97 and I'll play it
worked itself 7-5 will take I will take
I guess and play Bishop b5 I could have
also taken d7 and play tonight at 7 - in
fact I think now I'll just play it like
this it's now I've got night f7 at the
end and here I've got two pieces for the
rook as well so it's ok I'll play a
dragon this time see what you want to do
well no line
has it gotten disconnected it looks like
he has so try and use this extra time
that I have to to think
g-dog sixteen writes naka YT of a fan
instead of airconditioning um I'm
actually on the first floor I'm not
upstairs so I do have the AC in my house
but but it's not super strong and the
study down here on the first floor so
that's why I'm uh that's why I'm uh how
else why we found going so uh instead of
the East
I do have AC on of course but it's why
the fan right next to me
to a 3/8 is a strange move clerk ta hear
me a queen c5 probably all display Queen
c7
and she's really pissed off five
this would be three I'm gonna play
community five now because now he's got
problems on on a one two because no I'm
threatening Queen eight one as well
whoa there's picks up five really Wow
okay um which way to take or do I
Queenie one King D - no I've got nothing
okay so I'll just take the fish spawn
out five attack the pond enough three
hmm
I can play e5 I can put you know six
hopefully work b5 here on Queen c6 I've
got rook c8 it's a queen d4 I think
maybe I'll play no I'm not gonna place
if I'm clear what b8 we've kind of
messed this up again for no good reason
we're alive but put myself in a bad spot
so when I play Queen h3 maybe clean off
to I know who's gonna play like now I'm
gonna go back clean out five see what he
wants to do so when you for I'm I'm
obviously not gonna take a draw play
like we now fire queen bee force c5 or
something
so now I just Laden to place c4 so I'm
not playing good moves not the best not
the good news right now it's not gonna
get it done so I'll play e5 whoo whoa
well what was that what was that
jeez well now somehow he's completely
miss played at two so it's only it's
gotten really messy out of nowhere the
other side mean this never should have
happened obviously and somehow is just a
ridiculous draw no it's ridiculous
absolutely ridiculous
all right last six games last six games
then I'm done for the night and I'm
gonna win them all so ridiculous
Queen d8 oh I think I'll play Knight a5
now I'll just move my fish back to off
wanting guy p8 works c1
in b7 now I can check yeah i yeah i
think i can just chuck and take the
bishop on top 6 don't play like I don't
know Queen c2 looks really really nice
because now I'm King g7 I get Knight a5
I know
well this play clean b1 here get out of
any discoveries on the C file now I've
got this great Knight are now 5 which is
which is really nice rook g8 I think
I'll play d4 maybe
I guess he is 98 for maybe I guess it's
a move
so Queenie six I'll click beam b3 b5
only move no I'll just redraw my piece I
think I'll play like 92 probably work c8
and I had a four or a Knight d4 d4 can't
I just take or actually Knight d4 might
even be stronger
yeah just 94 looks really strong in this
a b3 Knight c3 work t2 I'm just uh maybe
maybe it's not so simple 93 to 95
so if t2 and 85 rook c8 we want to play
Bishop f3 but now I think I can just
play rook see - and I'm not I mean to
give them two pieces for the rook here
okay that's one
uh-huh he wants to play the four nights
a 94 tanks take or like Bishop c5
3d6 I only read some kind of pretty
pretty boring ly standard us sort of
like four nights Spanish type stuff so
between g5 try to take advantage of this
week pawn here on on d5
click queen g6 you know for one play
rook e8 I feel like gotta know like
Bishop d7 or something
I had bishop before maybe May 3 I'll
play a five
extremely b5 the Spade - I'll probably
play 8th for just to fix fix the pawns
walk is Bishop and no upload h5 let's
clean up for again I'm gonna play Bishop
e6 maybe now there's some Bishop a5 idea
lurking I don't know if it makes much
sense but click we got five Jim give him
a couple exchanges I'll take off the
dish base by our chief I'm gonna play g5
here
plus f4 okay f4 is interesting it's not
plate roar bishop f2 okay where whoops
he doesn't fish golf - yikes
hmm okay off six takes takes his bishop
here is kind of walked in though it's
kind of hemmed in a little bit so
the three applications t7 just to
retreat the bishop takes takes because
now a3 I think is weaker than eight
eight four so can be to hopefully King
of seven I think the one I'm just gonna
feel like king of six c3 I think I'm
just gonna start walking with my king
walk my king in as close as I can here
merrily vitiated know probably play for
Bishop of seven maybe yeah I think I
will cuz now his pawns are on the wrong
squares here they're on light squares
and this Bishop can attack them like if
I get Bishop takes d5 I've got this
takes G - so okay please Fishbach -
against if I take on c3 takes takes
takes Bishop d5 takes takes that looks
like it's winning or wait if I take take
d6 oh he's got some d6 mod sounds if I
take takes takes takes d6 okay so now
I'll retreat my Bishop to b6 line so now
I'm trying to just take on C turn that
and then take on and then take on d5 so
now this should just be winning
submission fee one now if I take he's
gonna take and go see four so I can't
really let that happen
so I think I'm gonna probably move my
came over one square to f5 so now he
goes Bishop b5 but now he's just losing
now I can just take on d5 cuz the g2 is
hanging I take on g2 he's got this your
d7 or Spit on c4 I can go King e6 and
Bishop d2 no okay never mind
blade bish PA now it's just all over
I'll play fish about five five Bishop a7
to cut the cut cut off any nonsense here
I think I'll probably each three is not
the right way for a seed so here I
should probably play between e5 and king
of for now this should be waiting
so it's a form worn out for more all
right
rookie aeroplane it2 and probably just
like Knight G 3 cheese 6 I'll play
I could play 95 here I think I will
actually just to see how he wants to
respond to this
so it's a play Brooke ACH I'll play
Queenie to here try to take take
advantage of this pawn on a6
so it does take in fact so it takes so
we have a slightly imbalanced pawn
structure here should be fine for black
but I do like the imbalance
it's Queen b6 I'll play play Queen b7
but I'm gonna click Queen B 5 here so
I'm Queen B 7 he could go c5 and it was
Queen on b5 c5 is not a huge issue here
I gonna play like rook D one fret to c5
rook do one probably hopefully Queen c6
I would assume he doesn't so he plays
repeat so I'm gonna read reroute my
knight around to the Queen side here
maybe like Knight f4 v g6 I'll take put
like work D - maybe or AIF oh let's play
a four stop any Queen side expansion
over here
I play a five takes oh it is d4 shoot
not good
oh wow
oh I can't even take on us six oh geez
oh geez okay some reason I thought I
could just take on take there but
actually now he's miss player now it's
unclear now I've got some chances again
because now I'll ignite a fake coming as
well like night you for night off 894
probably don't have that 94 I can play H
or no night before I can play workout
for and then I'm turning her cage for me
so he can't go to eat for g4 so you can
only really go to d5 wait you can't I
take a three workout for non-threatening
meat on one other cage for and now I've
got Rick a4 voila voila there we go
three more to go three more
Oh is he's not gonna play anymore really
that's rather silly
hmm
all right so let's see them so who is
service who's around let's see hmm maybe
GM yeas I assume that's the Asura let's
see if he wants to play he doesn't want
to play okay let's see
so far exclaims yassir's climb pretty
principled moves probably Bishop d6 okay
he plays f6
well played g3 play wait h3 maybe I mean
I don't know if I want allow to play
this page 3 or not but I think now I'm
gonna play c4 try to force it into some
kind of Benoni structure and now
hopefully a3 no excuse me
so a5 Bishop g2 h6
no
feel like Queen c2 must be southern what
to do or what to do what to do
I think I will play g4 and I think I'll
play like 94 now probably age 5 I'll
just take and play at night g3 rook up
seven or h7 sorry h4 and I think I'm
actually me castling queenside because
now the block has moved his rook he
can't counsel short so he's gonna have
to counsel Queen side too but I think
here I want to wheat I want to wait
until he counsels like I kind of want to
wait out week huh so no play Bishop d2
and try to play for b4 maybe basically I
just want to see where he's going with
his king
like its ego is he gonna play King off
seven is he gonna console long what is
he gonna do there
so please 98 I'm gonna play h5 maybe I
can get night age for 96 and plain ith
for
so goes night of seven so I have this h3
here possibly looks like a reasonable
move actually Bishop h3 is 93 maybe
maybe that's what he's playing for I
don't actually know what he's playing
for then again I don't know what I'm
playing for either so I'll play Queen c1
maybe Bishop efore was also possible I
don't know so now he does go off five so
let's force my hand so I'm gonna go
night g6 probably work h7 and then play
like I'm gonna play p4 here offer offer
to open up everything on the Queen side
it's fish about six I think I'm going to
get greedy grab a pawn here on the Queen
side open up this B file now here I
could please c5 if I want but I'll just
play work b1
so I guess we'll see here so you guys
King off seven so now I'm gonna I'm
gonna play Bishop g5 try to exchange
them stuff over here although I forgot
that I left a five hanging
if I take on off six if he takes on she
thrive my cakes in five wait doesn't
that just hang a queen oops
so you guys are played pretty well that
game
[Music]
so let's see what he wants to do this
time around please e5 I'll play c5 and
eighty seven eight six six
again I want to put like push basics so
here I'll take please see for complete
eighth five also a 500 is please see
floor
Bishop e7 tried to keep developing a for
I'll play a six just to keep him and
Chuck in line here so he can't he can't
blast it open on the queenside dumpling
97 now I'm a good chief five I don't
know why why not why not why not why not
when in doubt put age five I have one
play g4 I think I'll go g4 takes and
like Bishop g5 maybe
okay so he accepts the challenge or
takes it's for probably night h2o castle
he does a b5 here but I think I can just
play Knight a5 ah he has rookie three
that's a very good move the Queen e7
play Farouk g8
tonight f6 probably just rook g6 if
Queen a45 just work g7 is fine
9:06 I'm gonna play Knight of fate and
now I'm gonna go nitro sucks
I'm gonna assume he's gonna play b5 but
I don't I don't know if he has or not so
let's say I play like clean da no I want
to put another night on a5 if I can
but the answer is moving very slowly I
have to say he is moving extremely
slowly
so I don't see any real questions at the
moment so just keep keep playing 97 to
play for night at 5
please f4 ok now I can play Knight f5 or
work h4 even I think all those play or
night g8 up to this play Knight f5 mark
h4 o x3
Shh
and now I mean it's very hard for white
here I mean he's got a lot of problems
to deal so kingi - I think I can just
play like rook chiii can't our night
sheets or even maybe even just night G
393 looks crushing
so yeah all right what you do okay one
more one more for the road and this time
I'm gonna play Knight f3 I'll let him
I'll let him take on r3 I have this a
few times recently in the in the Blitzen
rapid in st. Louis the grand chest to
Irvine I seem to get quite a few good
position so why not why not keep keep
going for it
see it's g3 92
d for interesting okay I'm gonna I'm
gonna I'm gonna go for this I don't know
if this is good but it looks it's too
interesting to pass up so I black is
he's really we've doubled pawns and he's
pushes pawn to d4 here so it's gonna be
very hard to protect these these these
double isolated C pawns here so II sick
so I can take if I want to I don't
really want to take them so I take he
gets counter play so I'm gonna play rook
c1 so that I protect this pawn here so
he ever got to work to see a he's not
I'm threatening anything so hopefully
rook e1 I want to go rookie five next
move so he takes I'll take a ninety
seven probably is what he'll do I don't
know for sure
I guess he could also play like I don't
know what else he could do there so you
can go fish claw face and I'm gonna go
right doc with 90 to a 5 I'll play
Knight to c4 Knight these six I think
yeah although I just gave him 95 95 92
now why did they play nice why don't I
just blitz these moves I'm so stupid no
I'm kind of okay now I'm gonna have to
play Bishop b2 a foreign like III or
something now this is not really what I
was this is not where I was playing for
but it's still fine it's just I throw
away any advantage that I had before
although I am way up on the clock so
hopefully it won't matter so King f8 so
now I could play like Knight e4 maybe
but I mean I really don't like what I've
done to my position here it's just kind
of ugly so now maybe take and take and
take and take and take and take or
something and this is I'm kind of not
again not what I wanted to do
but we'll see we'll see we'll see what
is uh next couple moves are maybe I can
salvage us somehow so there should be
seven I'll clear display one offer an
exchange of rooks he probably won't
accept it but it's worth a shot
so let's see what he's gonna do here so
so gonna take her not know he's gonna
play rook e8 interesting so I'm gonna go
rook d7 and now I'm gonna go repeat one
probably King c8 just to kick my rook
back to be three now six I'll play up
the Kings you to here h6 oh please for
I mean he's he's got to start moving I
mean he's just moving way too slowly
I'll place eatery oh whoops
oh whoops whoops looks actually that's
okay cuz I can take and play rook c1 and
come on you asked her you got to move
come on what's he doing
yeah okay so all right so I guess that's
it I think I'm gonna stop since I got
back to 2,900 so um all right you guys
so I hope you enjoyed the the commentary
tonight I don't know what I'm gonna be
doing another one probably not for
sometime since since I'll be playing in
the World Cup so yeah so until until
next time I mean I'll see you guys maybe
I'll do one in Athens maybe but I would
say it's pretty unlikely but we'll see
so anyway I'll write you guys so I hope
you enjoyed the stream and I'll be back
soon hopefully with with with some more
more shrimp so I'll catch you guys later
have a good evening everyone
and have a good week all right bye